it's Thursday night I'm on the line most
nights I am because my girlfriend is a
bartender and a fine-dining restaurant
so we're like passing ships we know each
other really well but I don't think we
truly know what goes into each other's
jobs and I thought what would happen if
we swap it's not as easy as it looks
same sleazy I think she might cry it's
gonna be pretty funny I will after I cry
just finished up the shoot gonna have
lunch after I have flu you need to clean
your sink get your [ __ ] together I've
got my [ __ ] together I think it's coming
on to my hands what are you gonna shoot
what's your viral here it should be a
surprise
is it a porno not this time you direct a
great point I reckon I know you didn't
seem very keen on mine it is the other
night any part of my job that you feel
confident doing know I'm [ __ ]
hmm maybe we should have a few hours
tomorrow to kind of train each other
yeah you're gonna need it you have no
faith in me at all
let's do this okay we're going to Gwen
first and then we're Busbee yeah yeah
gonna get Holloway
I hate me sweet
[Music]
all right so he's gonna make sure you
don't stuff up the motor you need to
move back a little bit this I don't like
German eyebrow
you know you have a lens and what a
slip-up it's late I should
a little bit Gus
what if someone bottles there what do
you most nervous about
they are quite intricate cocktails so
just making sure we're putting our best
foot forward with everything that you do
so now we need to race back to BuzzFeed
this happens sometimes yeah some things
might not be working or missing are we
missing anything
we are just in a meeting still very much
getting used to filming everything that
I do
hey give me the measurements on the
multi 60 mils gin 20 mils no my first
moments wrong as well anyway I get
sleepy about 70 times Jane and I just
fearful today so I really suck at these
10 hours you should go back to bed you
have a very long day you'd only hit a
wall
I'm not gonna hit no walls [ __ ] lesbians
become I know we've got a wash on we're
doing the dishes with had a bath
masturbated and I've already vacuumed
actually thinks she's gonna do such a
good job I'm getting pretty nervous and
now I'm doubting why we did this at all
in the first place I don't know what I'm
gonna do today
justyou just pretend I'm champ any
questions you might have for ten I'll be
answering those today we have our media
tonight okay
so she'll text me and she's like what
you'll get T Logan up to you Michelle is
with us for a day making videos or the
plan to shoot and edit the video today
yes I was going to introduce the
Australian bin chicken is Ben chicken
they eat a diet solely of trash but very
little is known about them in America
what exactly is the video it's a pretty
extreme video format where I have like
chickens flying across the screen I
don't have those kind of skills but if
anyone's putting their hand up cool I
think we might have to think through
this a little bit more but it's a good
start you should get started now yeah
all right
you stole the dog it's my friends so I
think we're gonna go collect the mic
perfect thanks guys
cheers we're just coordinating now how'd
it how I'm gonna eat out of the trash
can
alright ready yep hi I'm Rochelle and
today I'm gonna be teaching Americans
all about the legendary Australian bird
being chicken
[Music]
Oh God that's terrifying
I just sent Michelle a text to check in
I'm kind of over having a morning off
maybe I'll just go to work early you see
for sure one said say hello I'm so
anxious it's lunchtime pants turn up say
hi I think she's kinda nervous hey maybe
you've already shot something yeah I'm
gonna get [ __ ] done how are you feeling
it feels like I'm going a five job in a
piece of
but I'm [ __ ] it up for you look
something easy
I think she might cry I can kind of hide
what I'm doing but she's gonna have to
do it in front of actual customers so
she can't really pretend like she knows
what she's doing if she can't deliver
the goods essentially I will laugh til I
cry
[Music]
when is a butcher slash restaurant
they're known for their like 30 and 80
day old steak I'm vegetarian I have not
even thought had a steak in my life I'm
most nervous about somehow poisoning
someone welcome is that it got some help
instead of the box like this yes
straight into it yeah prep station
capsicum juice cucumber juice orange
lemon egg whites the well they just pull
it down make sure you get everything
Rochelle can do it showed us three
Rochelle Rochelle Rochelle
[Applause]
so far so good nobody's need to see you
put together a drink
we're farmer days actually being created
cruzi so um she is that I know how do I
make this image all fit on the screen
command piece over at all
alright thanks Brett this is definitely
the hardest part how did I go back into
that the thing copy it then select them
all then copy
so we've hit five o'clock we're gonna
show the cut of the video that I made
it's eight minutes long hope everyone
brought their popcorn hi I'm Rochelle
and today I'm gonna be teaching
Americans of buzzfeed all about the
legendary Australian bird being shooting
I'm here today to inform you about
Australian wildlife have you ever seen
one of these before no what do you think
this is and that's how Australians are
born are you saying Australian to trash
[Music]
I don't think I'll be changing career
anytime soon
[Applause]
days done how do you think he didn't I
feel like I've done variety of different
things really challenged myself
technologically it's really impressive
that you were able to shoot and edit a
video in a day granted it's a really
long rough cut I think that you actually
have quite a bit of potential when it
comes to being a video producer but
there's still plenty of work you can do
yeah okay thank you
wait I ran into my friend and now we're
just gonna go get dinner together like
normal people
one two
actually that's your first one next next
we'll do our sour no flaring in the bar
nope bloody mucus beautiful beautiful
I think eggs coming onto my hands yep
delicious yeah beautiful are you happy
with those dude yeah our first ticket
yeah
first first customer they've ordered few
drinks I'm gonna do the man hadn't
because I don't know how to do the other
one delicious
what up best drink out
[Music]
yes how do you turn this song
my eyes everything
thank you very very much
it's too pretty I don't wanna drink I'm
just
good
what do you recommend a heavy need trust
me absolutely that's all I need it
is the martini
Rachelle's coming she's on her way they
get your [ __ ] together I've got my [ __ ]
together
yes she is look at this beautiful custom
boy Jeff oh yes yeah absolutely
need a drink My dear actually martini
dirty
this is my first classic
an Easter
wins
there you are
that's really good really yeah really
I'm like very legitimately impressed
making me proud bailout okay I'm gonna
get what are you gonna do it yet home
nothing nothing
[Music]
I wanna go I'm very individual all right
I think I'm gonna put you out of your
misery he's done really well but it's
not quite enough now so I can release
you into the night back into your
everyday life thanks for your help today
drinks were on point
you know how their old mentor tapes you
got that's one yay down I know I
understand now why Rachelle comes home
in so much pain
it's the
so real in saying that it's so fun even
bring happiness to keep it wide you've
done very well today should be very
proud you make good drinks but at ease
that was so fun but I am fully [ __ ]
dead hey hey what do you mean for God's
work house a day love the emotional
patience that is required to deal with
hundreds of people at once and then also
the internet is incredibly fatiguing Wow
maybe I had a better day than you I
actually had a really good day she was
weird but it was good what was your
video about game chickens oh did you
manage to edit it yeah
no way yeah it's like eight minutes I
didn't realize that so much of your job
as things that I actually like to do
like I like for things to line up and
present yeah it's a cute look it's so
fun yeah you know yeah it's creative in
a completely different way totally and
then to see the reaction of the customer
be like YUM I'm proud of you I'm proud
of you Smitty
I can't wait to see you [ __ ] video
and they're good I'm just for BuzzFeed
video I'm Rochelle just remember we're
all a little bit trashy
[Music]
you